are you excited to be here this evening
it's a powerful movie I've been a
co-producer from the beginning yeah
um I'm proud of the film I can't wait
for the public to see it
special guest in the audience tonight
legendary record executive Mr Clyde
Davis
it's gone what you start the show
tonight no talking back I'm Your Mother
I know he's a wanna dream up it is a
wonderful film I loved feeling all the
emotions and so many people in the
audience were clapping along after every
song and I love seeing Stanley Tucci as
you attend I always tell them I'm genius
casting but what will you always
remember about your first encounter with
Whitney that will stay with
David my first encounter this is vividly
portrayed in the film is when she
auditioned for me
a small Club Sweetwater
until the Greatest Love of All That was
the song I had commissioned eight years
earlier for the movie on the life of
Muhammad Ali and I was shocked he was
young
19 year old beauty went to the
microphone and sang the song as if I had
never heard it before she found more
meaning in that song than Michael masser
or Linda when they wrote it so I'll
never forget it and that's how we met
right after that old version what an
incredible story and of course then you
had to have had a last moment with her
that last encounter what will you
cherish about that last encounter that
you had with Whitney I don't think Karen
with Whitney was like 48 hours before
the
she was in great shape I've got to tell
you
showed me how old the nicotine from her
smoking had been removed
rescheduled the recording for August
that was in February she had just come
from her movie that
she had been in and I played her I was
playing her songs in general but Hudson
had just recorded we spent the whole
afternoon as we always did together at
my hotel so it was shocking shocking
when 48 Hours
what a wonderful way to have spent that
those last hour
when you hope audiences will take from
this film this evening
I want them to know the real witness and
that's why I was in this film as a
producer from the very beginning the
documentary the TV movie that come out
never captured her here you'll find
every answer to every question whether
it's her sexuality whether it's drug
whether it's how we work together in
music but then the music the music soars
your listeners have got to watch it in a
theater where the sound is real good and
those songs endless great standards but
it's the boy you will hear it's all the
voice of Whitney and you will hear her I
am so sorry for your loss and I know it
is so still deeply felt
and you are just you've created so many
Legends over the course of your career
sir and you recently celebrated a
milestone birthday so happy birthday and
another legend in the business Quincy
Jones he's gonna find himself
celebrating the same birthday here soon
is there an antidote that you can share
with us about you and Quincy working
together in the industry over the years
well you know I I'm sure I'll come to my
grammy party in February it comes every
year Quincy loves the party the Quincy
he makes it possible so indeed I send my
loved difference
what do you think it is about him how is
he led contribution how has he
contributed significantly to the end one
of the great great music men of all time
I mean his word going way back to
Nocturne uh miles and he spends all
kinds of music all generations uh he's a
master
[Music]